Je sais que ton père ne t'a pas donné une
enfance normale ou que tu commences tout juste
le lycée et c'est ta chance pour
un nouveau départ promet moi que tu essaieras
de vivre ta vie comme une fille normale
croise mon coeur espère mourir  d'accord
mesdames, commençons si trouver vos
tigres est
tellement
venu sur les suceurs de [ __ ] n'êtes-vous pas fatigué d'
être seul mais vous allez
appartenir à quelque chose de plus grand que vous
avez ensemble nous pouvons faire une différence
que dites-vous  tu gagnes pourquoi diable ne pas
essayer de t'amuser sinon quel est le
but des quatre prochaines années de ma vie à
essayer de comprendre qui je suis parce que je
connais déjà
cette fille
peut-être qu'elle est une [ __ ]